good morning again everyone my name is
reto Meier and I meani Lewis and it's
time for the developers of travel
planning and booking apps to strike back
every week we spend a lot of time
talking about other people's apps not
always nicely so today's show is a
chance for the developers of the apps
that we tore apart during the app clinic
put together again during Android design
and action
humpty-dumpty style to give us a piece
of their volume in last week's at clinic
we looked at these five trebled planning
apps we learned a few things not the
least of which is don't trust Daniel
Pham with the sound board also 5 apps is
too many to review we also learned that
people found out featureless black void
background to stock reminder of their
own mortality right did we have that
feature perspective black void are we
not doing that anymore at all I think
that I don't know do we still have two
featureless black background I think
we're not doing that at all anymore okay
yeah I'll take the blame on that one our
producers asked me to come up with
something that reflected who I was a
person and this is what I came up with
in terms of the apps themselves we came
up with the following prescriptions we
want the app to be consistent with the
design guide don't we always want that
we've pretty much always one that we do
yeah and in fact that's why broman keeps
dialing into all of our shows it's just
to make sure that we keep counting on
that dead horse
that's how why I'm pretty sure it's not
for the entertainment no it's not we
also want to make sure that these apps
in particular or location-aware we
wanted them to integrate with our
digital light you know I use Gmail on G
calendar for everything other people you
may know may use Facebook or different
types of things and integration with the
things that I use to organize my life is
it absolute must for travel absolutely
and you know when as far as that goes we
want to make sure that you can plan your
entire trip using the same app including
all those damn guided tours of my wife
likes to go on absolutely and climbs for
Chinese people and finally we want to
make sure that we can complete the
entire transaction on the device so we
don't want to get thrown off to a
website or a web view if at all possible
we want that all
right and I should mention just in case
I sounded racist my wife is Chinese
Chinese tourist that's why that makes a
lot of sense right exactly
all right so let's go ahead and take a
look at who we've got with us today
we've got Goran kokorin isn't world wide
web cams aundrea
bachata fast booking and Ryan Oldenburg
from Hipmunk who is joining us live in
the studio very exciting so he's gets to
see all of our disasters as they happen
in real time but he does not get to
appear on the table princess Leah style
as a hologram even though we totally had
that all set up and ready to go and
it'll happen it's coming soon and then
ratos like oh but if we do that then I
can't see my teleprompter and how I read
my awesome scripted Jose what exactly
let's go ahead take a look at world wide
web cams all right so that let's start
off by putting up on screen the the
ratings that we gave this ad we were a
little harsh mainly because this didn't
do a lot of the things that the other
apps do you were a little unfair
actually it was totally unfair and so
I'm glad that Goran is is here to tell
us just how unfair we were in person so
hopefully we've got we've got Goran
available on the Hangout if we can put
him on screen as well that would be
awesome
nice that's kind of a funky effect with
that background hey Garen I welcome to
the show I see you've got a partner with
you as well if you guys want to spend a
little bit of time just introduce
yourselves tell us who you are and a
little bit about world wide web cams
okay client ID law my father is actually
my son my two sons who both was involved
in developing works of wet hands my
20-round is either computer engineer
long time ago started with the expect
from Sinclair 81 nice July
gauged but now for years I'm not
professionally working in IT and
development but they were instructed by
Nextiva I'd reform for my birthday two
years ago and with the local competition
every development efficient I decided to
start to learn and read
Jayla is each sharp and she was already
known to me but chamber and therefore it
was something new and my team we
starting looking for idea wants to
develop the first first question we did
some research on the web on other app
stores and then we decided to develop
what's called web apps and in about one
month of laughter I'm working so in our
spare time
Worstell was born it was version 1 zero
and now three years later we have almost
half a million downloads and we're
looking forward to hear the in back-end
to implement the hints we received from
from you from Nick from Roman and I
think that you were doing next week's
all very cool so you've got a new
version queued up ready to go next week
thanks Elise
next week's ok it's a very important
clarification that's really cool now I
wanted to make sure that we got a chance
to to bring Roman up because I know that
in the at one point
worldscope webcams was going to be one
of the app Android design and action
candidates which I think got traded out
at the last minute so I do hope that
Romans got some feedback that that he
can share with these guys
your operandi yes why on the screen you
are I guess so we actually Nick and I
provided some feedback to Quran
separately on Google+ a bunch of the
feedback was really just around styling
basic visual things like they're like
one of the biggest points of ours was
that there was a case where you had the
map right you had the map in the
background and then image it is kind of
floating I guess thumbnails of the
webcam floating over the map and it
didn't seem like there was a purpose or
it didn't seem like there was a strong
kind of cue as to what was going on
there so we had made some suggestions
like maybe having a background behind
those images would give it a feel of
like a swipeable surface that you can go
you know up and down like that it's
actually a ListView
so we made a couple suggestions there
and made a couple of suggestions like
you guys said around I think it was a
last week in the Attic you mentioned
like around the search icon and things
like that so we've made a couple of
suggestions in general around visual
styling and things like that but one of
the reasons that we you know made the
switch at the last minute was that I
think it was just you know a little
easier for us to think of you know how
we can redesign TripAdvisor TripAdvisor
and worldscope webcams is such a unique
app that we can't just you know jump in
and redesign it for you that's part of
the like the interesting problem with
designing such a unique app is you know
think of a way to be unique and present
the awesome amounts of content you have
you know be the thumbnails the maps and
everything in a unique way and we didn't
want to do that for you yeah because he
didn't want to take away the magic right
no because always too hard work yeah you
know one thing that we said IRA last
week about world wide web cams is that
it seemed like it would work best in
conjunction with one of these other apps
I wouldn't I wouldn't want to say Oh
make it a plug in on another app because
we dinged a lot of apps for having too
many plugins yeah but this is
one of those times when I really wish we
had a you know an intent registry or
something where clearly you'd say you
know any travel apps that wants to use
the worldwide web cams functionality
could could fire off an intent and I get
that that kind of additional trip
planning feature absolutely Garn is is
that something that is already available
in your app or is something that you'd
consider doing so building an intent
that a third-party app developer could
use to launch your app and display a web
cam for you know a particular location
reacting Chiho intact and so when it
receives pollinates then you will get
lists of the specified location that's
really cool okay yeah I like that a lot
that's exactly the way that you should
be doing things like that so hopefully
some some of the other developers
building these sorts of travel booking
apps can can take a look at that and in
fact I think we'll we'll ask them as
they come up put them on the spot
very nice so one of the other comments
that we made that that I recall was I
think in terms of displaying the content
you know you've got this rich visual
content it's all about the pictures and
I think one of the pieces of feedback we
had was to try and make that an even
richer experience so you've kind of got
your full-bleed images with you know the
descriptive text overlaying that to make
it sort of more immersive is that
something that you guys are considering
like in terms of your overall UI pretty
happy with the direction it's going it
have you got any plans for making
modifications in that direction
questions question correctly but if
you're talking about your feedback from
our clinic I totally agree we go along
on everything you said
especially as dean Emily as Nick said
before that he decided to change in the
last minute so I decided to not to do
some things to be able to average up in
time and Tony already told Vince on
something one of those is really to to
use the first application screen as a
new pager so you'll be able to spike
left and right but in that case I think
I will leave the map tab completely out
and put it somewhere else
question is where well that not not is
actually the poor poor functionality
when we want to search for webkinz near
specified at that point so I think
mainly to put the small search button in
the action bar which will then call the
map screen from this screen I think we'd
encourage you to not switch the screen
immediately when you bring up the search
but once the user is finished typing the
search then it's completely appropriate
to bring up that map screen very cool
yeah so yeah we definitely pingas when
you when you do get another relief done
do let us know we want to make sure we
go back to each of the apps that we've
looked at and take a look at at the
improvements and changes over time so we
are definitely looking forward to seeing
the the updates when you've got them
done absolutely thanks a lot for being
with us core Thanks
all right so let's move on before we run
entirely out of time I think we're up to
Hipmunk now all right so this is a this
is the prescriptions that we had for the
Hipmunk if you want to go through those
and me and Brian are gonna magically
change places in the background
absolutely I totally want to go through
those let me find a place where I can
read them ah so we felt it longer we
were pretty well on design guide
inconsistency but where it really shone
was being location where and integrating
with my digital life so let me introduce
Ryan he's here with us in the studio and
Ryan tell us a little bit about yourself
and your company sure sure so hip MOOCs
goal is basically to try and take travel
search which is something that everyone
kind of has to do when they want to go
on a fun trip but isn't in and of itself
all that exciting or enjoyable of an
experience and really kind of improve it
and especially make it more
mobile-friendly it's it tends to be a
little bit of information overload and
so what we've really tried to do is get
a lot of information across in a very
visual way and the biggest thing that
that's led for us is a lot of fans of
the app we've we've taken the Android
design guides very seriously we haven't
done it perfectly but you know I think
everybody's trying to to find exactly
how their brand and Android can really
work together and you know a little bit
of harsh feedback is all it takes to
really get you to look at something a
new way and that flexibility ends up
with a much better app so I wish we
could show me the app on the screen
today we had some issues with our MHL
connector which I'm not sure that many
of you can sympathize with but I've got
yep information once you tell us a
little bit about you know what you
change if you could okay well the first
thing I definitely agree with is that
the the home screen is kind of a
dashboard kind of a list and androids
kind of moved away from that the only
thing that that I'm afraid of if I give
this up is the these like unavoidable
knowledge a user has the moment they
launch the app of what this app can do
if you use a a little thicker on the
Left which I actually did do on tablets
where this really was very awkward I did
unfortunately get a couple of emails
with people asking how to get from hotel
search to flight search which I launched
them into hotels at first right so
that's kind of made me a little timid
about
what approach I'm thinking of taking is
instead of instead of kind of getting
rid of a screen like this make it more
useful of a screen so instead of hiding
the recent searches often flights are
often hotels maybe I could put them
right here in front so you can pop right
back where you were what last time you
launched the absolutely this is really
tough and I think we we've had to deal
with this a lot as we've switched from
the old gingerbread design guidelines
into the Ice Cream Sandwich world is a
lot of these things are not discoverable
on their own but they become obvious
over time you know the same way that it
used to be that any hyperlink on a web
site was you know underlined and in blue
and I had a really sharp click me
attitude to it and now a lot of times
you won't even see hyperlinks
differentiated until you hover over them
because people know how they work and so
we're hoping to get to the point where
people just know how left side
navigation work and that's one of the
reasons we harp on it but you're
absolutely right that adding more
discoverability especially for new users
is a great idea um I want to go really
quickly to Roman to see if he's got any
ideas of how you can make things
discoverable without I always pretending
the user with a dashboard that's right
as soon as they log in yeah so I mean I
think that the point about first
lectures to talk a little bit about the
dashboard I think the point that Ryan
you're making about having like a more
content rich dashboard that's a good
start I mean if that becomes a less of a
dashboard and really more of a like a
dashboard a true dashboard but basically
I think that's that's kind of playing
into what actually one of the mock-ups
that we did for a kayak was like instead
of having you know a decision between
hotels and flights actually show the
user all this information in one place
centered around the concept of a trip
and at that point I mean they don't have
to think about you know is there a hotel
functionality started you know a flight
functionality he was thinking the
concept of like
I have a trip and here are the different
things I could do with my trip but to
talk a little bit about the
discoverability this is something that
users of newer devices are being trained
on so as soon as they launch Maps as
soon as they launch Gmail they're
learning they're starting to understand
what the spinner navigation is so while
you know there are some users that you
know that you just not ever touch that
we're doing a better and better job of
training them so lucky and said I
totally agree over time this will be
less than less of a problem but I mean
in terms of other things you couldn't
have kind of a um you know pop up you
know like kind of blue circle indicating
hey there's more stuff here we don't
recommend generally doing that because
things like this action bar spinner
should be discoverable on their own but
if you absolutely must direct attention
to something you could do something like
that and I think we mentioned this last
time but there's an open-source project
called showcase view that can kind of
give you that rich you know zoom in to a
specific UI element you know one thing
we need to do in video games that I
think would be really difficult like
there would be an incredibly difficult
machine learning exercise but with a
video game is a lot easier you could
detect when the user was frustrated and
when they couldn't figure out how to
pass the level and give them hints yeah
you know I'd love it if you could say oh
well okay now now I'm getting a like
Clippy territory but obviously hotel
it's up here yeah I like the
task-oriented view though with a shirt
the idea that the navigation is
something that would jump you ahead or
behind in the task without having to you
know be the only way yeah I I in to say
some famous last words in the spinner
I'm looking forward to the day that that
is just the way you eye works on Android
I feel like that's a great way to do it
dashboards are they were kind of a
solution to a problem that's now been
solved better and we're just kind of
waiting for the mainstream to catch up a
little bit yeah I think you know it's
been mentioned a couple of times already
but I think that the solution which
roman's describing actually fits in
really well with one of your key points
which was the ability to plan your
entire trip and so you sort of getting
away from that
I want to plan a flight I wanna book a
hotel and you're just saying I want to
organize a trip and then there's a
logical workflow that sort of goes there
so if you haven't done one of those
elements you kind of prompted that hey
you booked a hotel but how you gonna get
there so you know being able to sort of
flow it that way could be quite
interesting particularly if you can have
it enter from whichever vector people
want to you know want to start no and
then the these sort of navigation
doesn't feel like you go into something
and come all the way back out it's kind
of a circle yeah I think that could
really really work very well cool no
let's talk a little bit about this yeah
my favorite part of the feedback so our
our location selector when you're trying
to say where you're flying from a where
you're flying to has a pretty critical
flaw in the current live version which
is that if the place you're trying to go
isn't in our auto correct library and
you you hit the done button on the
keyboard
it actually nukes whatever you've typed
out of existence and this is just you
know it's a perfect example of something
I don't personally do and so I just
never knew existed until I stared it
right in the face on a clinic so that
was the best feedback I got cuz I'm sure
there's more than one person out there
annoyed by that right so this is where
it for those of you can't see that the
phoneand so where I type in V and I play
thinking about Venice gives me the
choice of either Venice Florida or the
Athens International Airport and yes I
try be clever
morning
oh okay believe in giving Venice Florida
where the Athens International and I
think to myself Oh neither one of those
is correct so I done on the keyboard I
just want it I'm typing and then it
nukes what is so this is actually an
interesting thing I've since fixed ed I
haven't released the update there's a
few other things I want to do too and I
like to not be too annoying about this
but the reason I do it is that I I found
that when I typed into one of these
autocompletes
I would say you know San Fran and I'd
say San Francisco and then Big O
actually I didn't want that when I
wanted South San Francisco arbitrary
example and so on the next click I knew
whatever was in there and then what you
would just type pops down and a little
hint ER the nice thing about that is you
never have to backspace like 30
characters you didn't want which is kind
of extremely annoying right the downside
of that is I didn't have the case
handled for that done on the keyboard so
I was thinking you clicked on it again
but you gave it focus again amazing done
and so whatever you type was gone
you know I I have to say I think that
you've got a really good point there but
I feel like there's more to it than that
because a lot of times is I've seen
things that do behave the way that
you're describing um in fact chrome does
this sometimes in it it really just
chills me I feel like I'm typing a
search and what I really want is
something very similar to one that I've
already surged but not quite exactly the
same and so I want it to autocomplete
and then I want to be able to change it
slightly yes so chrome does that to me
too like if I if I search two words but
and then I go back and want to starts
just the first I'll type the first it
hit enter it'll zoom I meant the whole
two words me like no that's not what I
meant at all exactly so but I think we
all loved your flight search results
page that's my favorite part of the app
and I think that's pretty true for
everyone and especially the way it
integrates with a calendar and the agony
thing that's awesome although I think I
mentioned I really wanted more to it
yeah
so so the the balance we're trying to
strike there is like the best mobile
apps tend to do like a core set of
things and it's easy to like keep adding
features as you you finished some and
you kind of have the dead of time or
whatever you know something like that
and and like frequent flyer miles you
know selecting preferred Airlines and
all that stuff could be really cool to
tuck in there somewhere but I I don't
know if I'm entirely convinced that not
just keeping it very simple is the worst
idea well if I think you're absolutely
right it but I would counter with
through you know what's worked for us at
Google which is you want to keep the
interface very very similar I don't want
anything to change in what I just did
it's sure but I want to have that
magical feeling of realizing oh hey that
the results you gave me fit my life
perfectly because I don't just have a
calendar I also tend to fly this airline
or a1 at Windows feed or mmm you know
I've got these many I heard flyer miles
well you make a good point distinction
between you I like screen space being
taken up by something in actual
functionality mom it is actually not
unreasonable to think we could add that
in sort of like a settings screen where
you don't even have to know it exists it
doesn't clutter anything to do with
what's already been done but you can get
the benefit of it if you want that's
absolutely and there are a few things
like you know for instance the the agony
of a particular flight goes down if this
long layover happens to be in a place
with a really good freaking fire club
first definitely but what are the what
are the color codings mean so the colors
are specifically chosen to be but you
guys hit on it when you wouldn't like
what that clinic its to do with the
airline so it's alternate Lu unite Delta
is Orange United's blue and na is like a
light blue we tried to do it as true to
the colors they've picked it for their
brand as possible in truth we could have
done arbitrary colors but since it was
already going to be kind of a rainbow we
tried to give as much meaning to it as
possible um for most people who don't
really care about the names of the
airline or the color of the airline it's
just nicer looking
a whole bunch of the same color that's a
really good point I would love to see a
feature where is you're separated by
Alliance because there's only like four
alliances and make any difference at all
so well that's the the biggest thing is
often people think they want to prefer
two airline but really they want to
prefer to lie it's absolutely and so you
know stuff like that can really can
really uh really yeah I can see how you
could really chance things around well I
think we're almost out of time but sure
that's just really quick talk about the
hotel search which we thought was very
similar in a lot of ways to play search
it felt like some things were missing
like there yeah there weren't as many I
don't think you have the the previous
searches listed yes um so I do I do have
them in the background but the big
design goal when we originally designed
hotels or what I call tell us which is
our hotel search product was that you
you were always looking at the map you
never lost this anchor which you guys
even picked up on in their clinic
because you couldn't really get away
from the map until you had picked a
hotel the downside of that is there's
not really room to put a big list that
needs a bunch of screen space and so
really it was one of those things we
just kind of had to give up and what I
liked about potentially bringing
combined list of recent searches to the
dashboard is suddenly you haven't given
up that recent search a list and and I
think that can can make up for it in
general flights his flights and hotels
were both designed in two different eras
so flights was originally designed to
spec when gingerbread was the king and
ICS didn't even exist in honeycomb was
just on tablets which I think it always
just on tablets but just on early
tablets then I did hotels before I had
an ICS phone even though I think it had
been announced on and so the the flavor
of the time is like very visible in the
designs flights I've done a lot of work
to bring it up to ICS I'm moving over to
doing that in hotel
but that's why while there's an action
bar it's kind of not quite right and why
there's two floating buttons on the
bottom left as opposed to a vertical
action bars at the time these things
just didn't quite exist for me um and so
and so you know just the flavor of the
time but I look forward to fixing it
awesome well I think that given given
what you've told us you know about when
it was designed I think you've done a
fantastic job sir I really appreciate
you coming in things ya know definitely
it's been great why don't we bring Rito
back up here and just talk about our
very last app which i think is kayak
well actually we we kept them in the
same orders last time so we just in case
mentioning time exactly just in the off
chance that one of the kayak folks
stopped in while we were on air and they
haven't as far as I know I'm a skip skip
past kayak and and instead I think we're
gonna have a look at fast booking which
we have on drea Pechanga
available on a hangout on air for us all
right Andrea hey how are you very good
thank you for joining us what time is it
Dean I'm gonna go ahead and presume
you're you're in Italy at the moment yes
I am an either so ten after nine right
now that's a reasonably that's a
reasonable time so where where are you
located Andre sorry where are you
located what City I am you yes Lou which
is a city near - you know 30 kilomiters
from ladies Oh quite close done nice so
yeah so you developed a fast booking in
fact where we looked at your app because
you ping me and said please take a look
at fast booking so huh so we did and I
think we we gave quite a bit of feedback
I think some of it was a little critical
so I really want to give you the chance
to uh tell us a little bit about you
know the concept behind the app how
happy are you with it where it is now
and sort of what are your plans for how
you may want to improve it in the future
yeah well we we decided to have a new
version of first week not to come
application because we already had the
ones before but it was designed a couple
of years back so the design was a
well it was okay at that time but now
was outdated so we decided to have a new
revamped design that well so we did a
new version of the way the application
we decided to have a flat design with
flat buttons we decided to have it same
color palette that we have in the first
booking.com website so actually the
cross scheme can change because we have
the same colors on the website so that
we decided web button the the the color
identity of products particularly for an
app like this it's a reasonable chance
that you can have people migrating from
the web to the phone and vice versa so
having that consistent branding I think
makes a lot of sense yeah so well we
decided to have this application the new
version and we as already said with a
redesign it from scratch the basic
features of the application is that you
can actually find 12 based on the
checking date number head of idols and
the number of nights and you can search
for city and then you can go for and see
for the reviews the other information
the Auto Gallery for the pictures of the
rooms and etcetera that's right that was
the thing which we highlighted is one of
the real features of the app I think was
the gallery with the the rich photos
looked really really nice yeah so and
then you obviously have the ability to
book the hotel and actually it also have
the ability to bookmark one so if you
decided to bookmark it and review it
later with your girlfriend
to see if she wants to go there and you
can book it out afterwards if you want
so it's actually only for a hotel
application you it's not like Hipmunk
that does almost everything in your tip
very well if the
and that's it I mean we have a couple of
things that I think it's interesting for
developers for example we have on the
booking form which is the booking page
where you enter your personal data like
first name credit card and address etc
in order to validate the booking process
you have a data validation procedure
that helps helps the user understand
where they failed to enter the data for
example if they enter a number in the
first name we are not saying you did it
wrong we are going to say near the first
name edit text we are going to say you
did it wrong because there are there are
numbers in there there should be only
alphabetical characters and this is a
nice thing that we didn't see another
application and well this is a one of
the most particular thing that we
created then we use a lot of caches in
order to cache the thing that we don't
load for example images that you get on
the list are not the only ones so if you
search Venice for today and you go
tomorrow and you reopen the application
tomorrow you're going to have the cached
content that of the regional looking
everything we are going to cache the
offers the rooms the everything almost
everything because we want it to have
the application to be smooth and fast
very so yeah that's I think that's a
really key thing particularly on mobile
which I think people who are used to
developing on the web especially don't
necessarily take as much advantage of
because for them it's like well internet
connections will always be faster the
whole thing's not going to work if
you're online so there's you know
there's not really the same opportunity
but for mobile doing that caching is
vital you know it's going to cut down on
your mobile traffic it's gonna make the
whole app just feel faster and more
responsive so I think it's a really
important step and I love data
validation that tells you what you're
doing wrong so thank you for that I
think there's nothing more frustrating
than hitting submit and you just get
like usually it's it's an alarm at the
top of the page which you won't scroll
to it just nothing happens except some
of your data gets erased if you scroll
back up the topic
yeah you didn't fill in something right
although I don't yes a you know it seems
like you're discriminating against
people whose first names do contain
numbers well I think when you change
your name so that the I was replaced
with the one that you were kind of
asking for trouble you know I am
actually a little sensitive to this
because when when I got married my wife
and I decided to hyphenate our last name
I and a lot of I think the - yeah that's
kind of harsh it's a lot of are you sure
maybe it's just maybe it's just that
like generally a keyboard only has like
the minus sign which isn't like an
en-dash and so maybe that's the problem
you need to get a room - it's an N -
well that's what either way either way
okay it's still it's still a - which
isn't isn't the same as either so next
time I have to assume that it would
always print out is like backslash
something going those Microsoft quotes
that you see everywhere
oh my famous favorite on wood when it
loses images it just has a big square
with a red X through the middle yeah
that's rough anyway so you know
something to think about yeah we love
the we love the validation that's it's a
little more lightweight and user
responsive we love the caching um we
just have a few more seconds left to go
Andre but can you give us any ideas
about what's coming in your next release
well in the next release we are going to
well fix some minor bugs that we add we
have we are going to have a better
Google Analytics integration so we are
going to track ecommerce so we are going
to know each transaction how much and
where the the transaction comes from we
are going to have a contact picker so
that the user will be able to feel the
booking information so first name last
name the one that we talked about before
for picking from the very contact list
so if if if you have your own contact
with the address the last and cetera you
can just pick your content and
everything is already filled for you
we are going to have a little a first
input and which are not available now
because you only are in the live version
you currently are able only to book the
the best offers the best offer only the
best offer and now you can choose
between the multiple offers so for
example if you want to choose for the
publisher and gas - the best one you can
just pay more and you can do it so
that's that's the stuff that is going on
in the next release very cool and I have
one more suggestion which I'd really
like to see you guys do because I'd like
to hear what kind of results you get so
I think from memory yours was one of the
one of if not the only app which didn't
have a feature graphic for it so when we
put up the big screen of all of the apps
that we're looking at you know we didn't
get to do anything but have an icon for
you guys so we saw a study on the on the
web that showed that one of the apps
which had been featured found that their
traffic doubled when they had a feature
graphic now it wasn't just having one -
it was also having a really good one
that's right that's right it has to have
one to be featured to begin with so they
went from kind of an in yeah graphic to
a really nice one and double their
install rate I'd be really interested to
see if you guys did something like that
create a feature graphic try and make it
as compelling and interesting as
possible and see if that has any impact
on your downloads
I rather suspect that it will but it
would be great to find out from you guys
whether or not my supposition is correct
well we will definitely do it and we
want that you know of course I look
forward to it all right thank you very
much for joining us Andrea thank you
okay so I don't think that the
TripAdvisor guys have stopped by so
we've got their scores up on the screen
get in a couple of seconds nope
so that I think well it truly puts us
out of time for today very much so yes
so let's have a look let's give a bit of
a shout out to stuff that we've got
coming up so next week's app clinic
we're looking at video players I mean
you're a dear to my heart indeed indeed
so the four apps that we're looking at
in fact going to be MX player dice
player Netflix and cine X player and
three of these apps have something in
common indeed they do not have a feature
graphic so we're really hoping that if
the developers of these apps happen to
be watching I happen to catch this on
YouTube that they go ahead and create
feature graphic sometime between now and
tomorrow afternoon or will create them
for them excellent of a faster on
feature graphic it should be fun
so this is gonna be tomorrow at a brand
new regular time of 10:30 a.m. Pacific
time yes although I did want to talk to
you about that because I'm usually
hungover them so we might want to change
yeah we'll have to look at it yeah in
fact you guys can let us know if we used
to do this at like 1 o'clock in the
afternoon which was on a Friday
afternoon late enough to not be
suffering from the hangover early enough
to start working on the next one so that
kind of had its advantages 10:30 works a
little better for our European absolu us
who don't have to you know stay up late
on a Friday night at home just to join
us in the Hangout in view but so this is
tomorrow so please please do tune in and
hopefully we'll get some of these
developers back next week the developers
strike back as well so that's all for us
thank you for watching and thank you
very much to all of our developers who
came in both in the studio and via
hangout to talk a little bit about their
apps take care and see you next week